pas les fêtes de fin d'année s'est fait
partie des moments clés de l'année qui
m'angoisse un peu parce qu'il ya un
enjeu social très fort et toute cette
phase ii il faut faire des cadeaux il
faut penser aux cons cadeau à la bonne
personne il faut pas vexer la personne
de dire ah merde il m'a fait un truc il
m'a offert un truc hyper cher j'aurais
dû offrir mettre un peu plus d'argent ou
l inverse
est-ce que j'ai pas mal donné à acheter
un truc trop cher par rapport et ça va
être mal à l'aise les autres on a aussi
peur de mettre mal à l'aise
[Musique]
la soirée du nouvel an c'est un c'est un
moment qui est peut-être le paroxysme de
langue c'était pour moi aujourd'hui où
justement j'ai pris un peu de recul par
rapport à tout ça et où ces moments là
sont faites restent les plus anxiogènes
pour moi c'est des moments où en fait je
sais que voilà je vais arriver dans un
lieu je vais pas forcément on connaît
tout le monde et je vais devoir
ben en fait déjà juste rentré dans une
conversation
c'est quelque chose qui paraissait très
naturel pour les gens et pour moi basse
et voilà il fallait que je me posais
plein de questions je me dire avant même
d'entamer une conversation je ne dirai
ce que c'est pertinent de commencer
comme ça en fait j'ai l'impression
d'avoir un flot de pensées constants
dont clash en train de dessiner le un
personnage que dessine tout le temps
c'est le cri de mouches c'est devenu
comme un smiley en fait pour représenter
l angoisse
même une fois que j'ai réussi à
m'intégrer une orientation il faut que
je vais toujours me dira je suis pas je
suis pas assez intéressant je suis pas
assez fun le fait de poser tout c'est
que de se poser toutes les questions là
ça me rend pas très fort et je pense
et du coup ça fait une espèce de
pareilles de cercle vicieux et je vais
me comparé aux autres personnes qui
parlent je me dire à west ham alors dit
ça pas bête
par contre c'est à dire sa bonne blague
mais par contre moi il faut que je sois
en fait je me sens je me compare je
tends ni comparaison comme ça
au mental
[Musique]
donc c'était généralise serment le
moment où ou toute forme de situer
toutes situations en fait va créer de
l'anxiété chez chez la personne d'être
sociable de rencontrer des gens
discutent et d'interagir créer des liens
sociaux s'endormir le soir tous ces
choses là c'est chose qui pour moi comme
s'il manquait un manuel à la naissance
que j'avais pas eu et que je dois
réapprendre en fait voilà je fais un
dessin où je suis chez moi sur mon
canapé comme ça je regarde les réseaux
et je suis un peu paniqué parce que je
vois ce que font les gens ils sont à
l'étranger ils font des trucs qui ont
l'air sympa qui sont ils ont l'air bien
et moi je suis chez moi du coup je suis
un peu en stress clairement depuis que
je fais la série ça va mieux et je sais
pas si c'est durable s'il va y avoir des
relents faut voir mais dès lors qu'on va
être qu'on prend un peu de recul et en
fait on se rend compte aussi que
l'anxiété c'est drôle enfin ça avait
quelque chose de très drôle en fait
parce que c'est toujours des situations
extrêmes vécu comme extrême mais qui
dans la réalité sont vraiment anodine
c'est des situations de quotidienne et
je pense que plutôt que de se dire
[ __ ] mais je suis ridicule pourquoi
est ce que je pourrais ce que j'ai réagi
comme ça on va tivo il vous faut prendre
avec humour en tout cas moi c'est ce que
je fais je trouve ça juste tout rôle en
fait c'est ça rend la vie un peu plus
rigolo quand